I'm sure I'll be able to recover so I
thought it was a good idea to switch to
a Mac just recently and apparently that
was not such a good idea
I'm just kidding let me just log back
into my machine here we're going to be
talking about c-sharp and what's new in
c-sharp as a programming language I
generally joke that c-sharp is turning
into F sharp and that's not necessarily
A Bad Thing
because taking inspiration from other
programming languages that are available
on the market like F sharp switch
kotlin Java and so forth it's a good
thing that the language designers keep
talking to each other and looking at
each other's programming languages so
hopefully in the next few years what
we'll see is that we'll get more
features in c-sharp that are inspired by
programming languages like F-sharp and
taking inspiration from all of that
which is not necessarily a bad idea
so fortunately enough this machine
booted up rather quickly
and hopefully I've recovered this
let's just resume this as well
all right
so we're going to be talking about
what's new in C sharp and things that
have been added to c-sharp as a
programming language over the past few
years we're going to be going back a
little bit further than c-sharp nine
just to get a little bit of an
understanding of some of the features
that have kind of built up to what we're
going to see in the next coming versions
of c-sharp as well
my name is Philip Ekberg I've written a
book on c-sharp I've got plenty of
plural side courses on the topic so if
you like my stuff feel free to reach out
and ask questions afterwards if you
don't like my stuff you can tell me as
well send me an email talk to me about
what's what's bothering you what what
kind of things you're you're facing in
your daily work that you'd like some
help with I love discussing programming
languages a lot of talking about c-sharp
and Dot net in the future of mobile
development and all of that
but today we're going to be focusing on
c-sharp and what this language is
becoming in things that have changed
over the past decade or so if you're a
developer that have worked in c-sharp
for the past 10 years and maybe been out
of it for a while it can be quite hard
to get back into it and understand where
these new language features all make
sense
so hopefully after this session you will
get a little bit of an inspiration as to
where these features make sense and how
to add them to your application
some of these language features will
change how we look at the architecture
of an application some of them change
because of the available tools to us and
the available machines and where we want
to Target our applications to to be on
as an example of that
15 years ago maybe mobile development
wasn't as big as it is today obviously
it wasn't because it wasn't as
accessible
so now when we have mobile applications
we have iot devices they all need to
consume resources asynchronously so why
not make it a part of the language to
allow us to do that so async in a way it
was introduced in c-sharp to make that
easier and there are more language
features like this that quite quite
drastically change how we build our
software ultimately it means that we can
write less code to do the same thing
hopefully it's going to be less error
prone and we can achieve the same result
with less code and less errors but that
also means that we need to understand
exactly what all of these features are
doing
another example of that is pattern
matching it's also generics they
drastically change how we look at
building our c-sharp applications
so how do we keep track of all of these
different language features
and what about if I have opinions on
what they're adding to c-sharp I know
we're developers we all have opinions
but if we have opinions on what's coming
in C sharp and we want to participate
maybe even help build the next version
of the compiler we can jump on to GitHub
and do that there's a Rosslyn repository
which was the code name for the rewrite
of the c-sharp and VB compilers
we can participate in discussions and
look at the language design meeting
notes and understand the reasoning
behind why certain language features are
added to c-sharp
this is also a good place to learn
exactly how to use them and where they
would fit in different types of
applications there are many developers
that join the discussions to just learn
from others how this would be applicable
in their applications
so if I'm not interested in just jumping
on GitHub and implementing language
features in the compilers I just want to
use these in my new applications it's a
little bit different than what it used
to be
so now we have to be on a very
particular version of
both.net
and visual studio to be able to leverage
these language features
if only you see Sharp 8 and you see
nullable reference types for example we
have to be on dot net core 3.01 later
the reason for this is because some of
the features that the language allows
you to use requires both updates or for
the SDK as well as the runtime the
runtime will help to understand exactly
how to run certain things
but most of the language features that
we're using C sharp they're just
a compiler magic or it's just what the
compiler is doing it's just translating
your c-sharp code into IL
so what if the IL that it produces would
be compatible with an older framework or
an older runtime
while it's an unsupported case you could
use c-sharp 12 for a dotnet framework
2.0 application as long as you're using
features that are compatible with that
runtime
it's not saying that you should do this
but you can
which means that the only reason for
upgrading for the new.net versions would
of course be performance but if it's for
the language versions you only need to
update or jump onto the newer version
of.net if you're using one of those
features that are requiring a runtime
change
so before we jump on to C sharp 9 10 11
and possibly what's happening in 12. I'd
like to just talk about a few highlights
from c-sharp 8 which set the scene for
what's going to be developed on for the
next few years
so in C sharp eight we got a few quite a
lot of language features read-only
members default interface methods or
default interface implementations
depending on where in the documentations
you read about this
we've got something called a switch
expression which changes how we use
pattern matching pattern matching is a
concept that's been available in many
other programming languages for a very
long time and just in in C sharp 7 it
became a first Cloud citizen in the
language but it's constantly being
developed so that's why we're going to
take a look at exactly what this is as
well
reducing declaration static local
functions nullable reference types which
changes how the compiler looks at all
your reference types you know if you're
creating an instance of a class that can
be set to null with this language
feature turned on the compiler will now
assume that you've always set this to an
instance
which is good because then we can avoid
potential problems but we'll get into
that soon we also got a way for us to
work with streams of data disposables
for synchronous programming rain this
analysis and not equalizing assignment
so being the eighth iteration of the
language we're not going to be looking
at all of these features but being the
eighth iteration of the language there's
still quite a lot that's been added to
it and we'll continue to see more and
more features added to c-sharp
now before we get to the more useful
language features there's an interesting
language feature that kind of
illustrates why you would need to be on
the a later version of the runtime so
with c-sharp eight we got this thing
called a default interface
implementation or method depending on
where you read about this
so what this is in why this is
interesting is because it kind of
divides developers into two different
camps
some Developers
really just don't like this language
feature at all and the rest really don't
like it
I'm kidding
there are some use cases for this so
default interface methods means that I
can now change my interface and Supply
it with a default method implementation
while I'm using an expression body
member I've now extended my interface
with an implementation detail
so why is this such a big deal and why
why would this require a runtime change
so prior to dotnet core 3.0 the the
runtime didn't know anything about how
to execute a method from an interface
because that was just a contract to
determine what the actual implementation
the class the instance what that would
have
so while this is this is a good idea
the problem is that the Tooling in
visual studio for example it doesn't
tell you if this is available
so imagine pulling down a nuget package
and update there's a default interface
implementation on that nuget package the
visual studio won't tell you that it's
there
so instead it will just use the default
implementation
so to solve this you all have to read
the documentations like we all do when
we're updating our packages everyone's
reading the change logs
if you're saying that you are I don't
know you're lying
now an important feature added to
c-sharp 8 which has been changed now
over the the last few language versions
as well we improved upon by adding more
features to c-sharp it's now coming to a
state where we can write applications
where we really avoid having null
reference exceptions and all null at all
in our language in our programs
the nullable reference types was
introduced to help us avoid a very
specific problem
as anyone here never seen this happen
you're lying if you're
I think all of us have probably ran into
a null reference exception
otherwise maybe this is your first week
as a developer and I welcome you to this
world tomorrow you're going to see this
in one of your Solutions
so this isn't only the problem with
allowing nulls in in the language other
languages like kotlin make it really
hard for us to use nulls the compiler
will smack you on the fingers if you try
to you have to explicitly say that this
here can be null and I can use null in
this context
but the problem with null ability is
also that it encourages that we add null
checks all over our code which clutters
the code it makes it harder to read and
understand exactly what's going on what
about if I can turn this around and put
the responsibility somewhere else I
could tell the consumer that you have to
explicitly say that you're passing null
here and I've handled that case
and honestly quite it's quite ambiguous
right so what does it actually mean to
return null from a method
so imagine implementing a repository you
communicate with your database
I know many developers myself included
wrap everything a try catch block and
just return all from the method if there
was a problem
now how would the consumer of my
repository know if the object wasn't
found or if there was a problem
now obviously it's a bad design from my
part but I know this happens quite a lot
there are better alternative ways to do
this we can with pattern matching now
say that we return a not found use it
unauthorized user removed or whatever
so many different ways to build this
architecture
it also encourages mutability if I allow
a property to be set to null then
there's an assumption that sometimes
this is going to be changed to in fact
have a value
if that's not the Assumption then you
can remove the property completely
and of course this is a problem with
multi-threaded applications
especially if you're doing async in a
way done a lot of multi-threading
so of course this here isn't a big
problem like I can now check I can have
a lot of code like this here and someone
in here much more than myself is going
to tell me that I can write this a
little bit prettier sure enough I can
use the null conditional operator and
write this a little bit better
but what if I can indicate to the
compiler that I promise that person
address and Suite will never be no
at least that's my assumption
how about I I tell the compiler that you
can try and keep track of the state of
nulls
we can do this by enabling the nullable
reference types and this is the default
since a few versions back so if you do
file new project this is going to be
turned on this here is the compiler
directive to turn it on or off for one
line one method an entire file
but per default it's enabled in your
csront file
so let's uh jump over to um
Visual Studio
which I had started earlier but now then
at this crashed let's see if I can boot
this up pretty quickly so in the um
and the Cs project file
this is now hopefully still turned on or
turned off
and we can enable and disable this
wherever we want so let's say that I
have a project here called nullable
reference types
I'm going to go into this project file
and I have these two properties I can
say nullable enable it's all commented
now
before I enable this I just want to show
you the the file itself or the class so
this is a very simple code file there's
no issues there's no compiler warnings
no errors no nothing like that
simple class
it's a simple usage I'm returning null
here because that's always a great idea
so at the first glance like this looks
like code that we've all written for a
very long time
but if I now enable this language
feature
which is the default from
c-sharp.net6 so going to be turned on by
default
now
I have a couple of warnings
look at this
so now to tell me that you have some
non-nullable properties you should
probably attend to these and fix this
how many of you are always fixing your
warnings
right
I don't trust that at all I'm kidding so
you can have style cops and whatever
enabled that tells you that this is a
problem but what I like to do
is that I'd like to go back to this to
really ensure that this is visible
I'm going to treat warnings as errors
and now
if I go back to the correct file
this will now be a compiler error
instead so now I can't even compile my
solution
so if you brought your laptop with you
today
and you're using an older version of
c-sharp or net go into your company
projects enable this check in the code
and take a long weekend
and then when you come back on Tuesday
or Wednesday
either someone's fixed all the null
reference problems or you're out of a
job the first would probably be better
but now that I've enabled this here sure
enough it's great that it's telling me
that there's a problem the problem here
is that the compiler can't ensure that
I've set this to a proper instance and
the way to do that is of course to
introduce a Constructor
now the compiler error removed somewhere
else because the the
the constructors should be in charge of
setting these values but if I start
adding you know first tier and string
last I have to set these two I can't
even type and talk at the same time
let's do first name is equal to First
last name is equal to last and now
there's no more compiler warnings or
errors
the problem with this approach is that
I've now changed the contract so
whoever's using this class will now have
to go ahead and change all over the
place
which is not necessarily a great idea
so how do we solve this well with C
sharp eight it wasn't really possible to
solve this in a nice way
you could of course say that well I want
to allow this to be null so nullable
reference types you know nullable value
types you can just add the question mark
and now that can be set to null so if I
start adding question marks all over my
code base now all of a sudden I went
back to where I were prior to enabling
this language feature
which is slightly true because now I've
moved this warning to somewhere else so
whoever's using first name will have to
ensure that it's properly null checked
I don't particularly like adding the
question mark like this here so instead
we'll do it for one of them but I'm
going to add two more language features
one that was added in C sharp nine and
one that's been added in C sharp 11. so
let's say for first name first name
should be required
if I add that the warning has now
disappeared so whoever's creating an
instance of this class are now required
to set this to a to an instance
and I can also introduce a C sharp 9
feature called init only to ensure that
once you've set this to a value you
cannot change this so effectively I made
this immutable
should probably do that down here for
for last name as well
it's better to create a new instance of
this detailed class rather than changing
the existing properties
and then for for this here it's
complaining up here as well so let's
just make that nullable to illustrate
what's going to happen next
so another another place in the
application I'm accessing the last name
and now the compiler knows that hey you
should probably have set this to a value
what's interesting is that the compiler
if I set this person.details if I set
this to a new instance
this here is going to complain that I
haven't supplied everything necessary
because it requires me to also set the
first name right which is great
that's what I want so if I say that I
want to create a new instance of this
first name is required I'm going to set
that to a value
then what happens if I said last name to
something
now it knows that I've set this to a
value because it keeps track of this
it's called null State static analysis
which I'm not going to repeat again
because it's the hardest thing to say
so that's a great thing the compiler
knows that I've now set this to a value
so what else can the compiler track well
it knows that if I perform a null check
in another way I can say person.details
dot last name if that is null
I can continue to the next one that's
not what I want
can do this
probably have to do details like that
now it knows that I've performed this
null check
but I can take it one step further to
say that well
what about if I use a helper method so I
can do argument null exception throw if
null
person dot details
and I'm going to do the same just to
show you how this works for last name
so the same thing here this method that
that checks if it's null or not how can
the compiler know that it's performed in
null check how does it know that there's
an attribute used on this method to
indicate to whoever's Now using this and
and to the compiler that if this throws
an exception you won't be coming to the
next line and I promise that it's not
null obviously we can trick the compiler
into thinking that we've performed a
null check
but that kind of defeats the purpose
so it's very flexible and it's a really
great way for us to try to avoid these
null reference exceptions and with the
required keyword added in C sharp 11
this became kind of complete because
what you had to do earlier
was quite nasty so if I remove the
required keyword and I want to say that
this shouldn't be null but I also want
to get rid of this warning so I could
say well I'm going to set this to the
default value and I promise that default
isn't going to be null and now the
warning disappeared but whoever is using
this here doesn't know
so to show you why that is a problem
we could say that
this here returns null the compiler now
expects this to be set to an instance
but you know
I can promise the compiler that I'm not
returning null
so why is this a problem
obviously we're not smarter than the
compiler so the damage operator
we should avoid that
especially with the new keywords in
c-verp 11.
so instead of course we should return
I'm going to use yield return new I keep
the target type new expression which was
added in C sharp 10 so I don't have to
explicitly say which type I need to
create
and since I remove the required keyword
from down here I'm going to set that to
a required again
now it tells me that I should probably
set first name
first name to a value right
there we go
so the nullable reference types is a
great addition addition to the language
but was only really in my opinion
completed now with c-sharp 11 released
last year and together with the target
type new expression that reduces the
amount of characters that we have to
write the code becomes rather rather
nice
and before we go any further so this
here is a program.cs file so before I
jump back this here is a top level
statement notice how you don't have to
have that public static void main stuff
it doesn't have to be wrapped in a
namespace nothing like that anymore no
usings at the top for the standard
system stuff this is the new way of
building your console applications or
also what's known as minimal apis
so again I do encourage you to um to try
this out and tweet warnings as errors
you can turn this on as well in the
project settings as well as with the
nullable reference types
and another just small note here on C
sharp a they introduce something called
asynchronous Stream So they continue to
add capabilities to language features
that have been introduced over the past
years like async and await was first
introduced in in dotnet 4.5 so quite a
long time ago in c-sharp 5. but now
they're they're keep adding things to
the language to make it easier to
consume resources so for for example I
can add the await keyword in front of a
for each Loop to indicate that I expect
each element in this for each Loop to
retrieved asynchronously
which is extremely useful imagine having
a message box in Azure for example or a
message queue you can say that I want to
iterate over each message I have no idea
when they arrive but I could basically
say a wait for each message in my
message queue and the body of that for
each Loop would then run for each
message as it's added in azure
quite handy we've been able to write
this code in different ways before but
now it's a little bit less code it's
more understandable but you also have to
understand exactly what async in a way
does and how it affects performance in
your application
so with C sharp eight out of the way we
can talk a little bit more about C sharp
9 which introduced a really important
language feature called records or
record types this is a way to more
easily Define a reference type in a
little bit more of a concise syntax
it added the init only Setter that I
just showed you
we had the top level statement which is
a new way of writing that program.cs
file
we've got pattern matching enhancements
I haven't even showed you pattern
matching yet but that's a big topic and
we'll call that cover that in just a
second with C sharp 9 they introduced
more patterns to the language to make
this a viable feature
they also added the target type new
expression that I just showed you as
well and there's a whole bunch of more
language features more targeted towards
I would say lower level stuff
but again like in the ninth version of
the language there's quite a lot added
right
it can't be easy maintaining such an old
compiler and still adding really
important language features
but that's why c-sharp is still so
popular because it keeps adapting to the
types of applications that we need to
build and the types of tools available
and the the different platforms that
require it
so we're going to be looking at records
and and pattern matching next pattern
matching has been around in many other
programming languages for a long time
kotlin Swift among others
what this allows us to do is to look at
an object or an instance and determine
what that is it could be in this case we
could look at if the fruit is edible if
it has a certain shape or if it's you
know anything you can think of
and I like to talk about pattern
matching as a way for you to take a
little bit of your code snippet and
share that with the non-techies in your
project
maybe they shouldn't be allowed to add
things to your patterns but you can
still talk about the the Expressions
that you're using a much more better way
than it used to be
as an example we can match on a type and
what I like to call an attribute and I'm
not talking about the attribute that you
have on top of a method or or a class
but an attribute in terms of what
something is
so in C sharp one through six we've been
able to do this we can say get give me
the type if it's type of what I'm
looking for and I can compare a certain
property now the problem here would be
if that property only lived on the
specific type that I'm looking for I
first have to perform that typecasting
and then I have to cast it to the
correct type if I'm using it in some way
inside that if statement
something wrong with this like all of us
probably write this type of code and
sometimes I still do because I forget
that pattern matching is so powerful
but with C sharp 7 they made this a
little bit easier and the goal here is
to make it so easy for anyone to express
themselves without having to write two
complex code and making it a little bit
more extensible as well
we all know that it can be hard if you
want to add it just one extra Clause
here to the if statement or one extra
thing to it we have to write lots of
tests to ensure that that it works
but with pattern matching it kind of
quickly becomes obvious unless you're
abusing the language feature which I'm
also going to show you how you do so you
can avoid doing that
now with C sharp 7 they introduced the
first version of this so with a switch
or the normal switch statement we can
pass an instance and say that for the
case of this being the type that I'm
looking for this is a type pattern I'm
going to capture this as the correct
type the compiler already knows that I'm
looking for in this case an apple it can
then capture it to that particular type
without me having to do anything
I can then access properties in that one
expression
and then it's the concrete type or the
correct type inside the case
obviously with C sharp 7 no one really
wrote this because there's a lot more
code to express the same thing
but this was the first iteration of
pattern matching in c-sharp so with C
sharp a they intro is a switch
expression which drastically changed how
we write this so instead we have this
line of code here where I expect a
result coming out of my pattern matching
code snippet So based on my input that's
the object I wanted to create patterns
for I create this switch expression
which I fill with expression body
members
that's an example how this would look
let's say that I want to get a string
representation of my type I can say well
based on my instance of a fruit create
these different switch Expressions if
it's the type of apple then I'm going to
return a string so the right hand side
is what's returned out of this here
could be a method call doesn't have to
return a string this is just a very
simple simple way of doing this
hopefully no one's now thinking that oh
you can only imagine a particular type
but surely enough that's the that's the
most simple thing that's a type pattern
so there's many different patterns
available in C sharp there's something
called a positional pattern if you use a
method called a deconstruct you can pull
an object apart and use it with what's
called positional pattern
it's not used as often as the other ones
but I can show you that as well
we have a property pattern to match on
property values we can have a tuple
pattern to match tuples with each other
we can do relational patterns for
example let's say that I'm looking for
users and I'm matching on an authorized
user where it's logged in within the
last few days
then I can do a relational pattern to
say that you have to have logged in
within 10 days
which you can still Express with a
normal if statement what with pattern
matching that little code snippet
becomes a little bit more fluent and
nice to read and I can even use
something called a conjunctive ant
pattern to say that well the user have
to have logged in within the last 10 or
and 100 days
we can do the list patterns to say that
I'm looking for a list where the start
of the list contains something or the
end I can slice off a portion of the
list if it's the correct thing I'm
looking for
and I can group these together with
parenthesis and I can I can negate them
with a knot pattern and there's all of
these used together produces what's
known as a recursive pattern
so surely enough there's quite a lot of
patterns available in c-sharp and we're
going to be exploring some of them now
so let's jump back over to visual studio
and before we explore the patterns
I want to go through this this
file that I have here so there's a
couple of things happening in here so
first of all
there's not really a namespace
declaration that you you normally see
I'm using a file scope namespace at the
top here to indicate that all the types
available in this file now lives in this
namespace
no more indentation no more useless
white space passed up to GitHub
right perfect and then I have something
called a record so this was also
introduced in C sharp nine the record
type produces a reference type it's a
class with quite a lot of functionality
behind the scenes here
so what this actually does and let me
see if I still have my browser open
probably don't since my computer crashed
let's do to sharplab.io
do a dare press restore
probably not
probably not so just trust me what this
is doing here so what it's doing is that
it's generating first of all it
generates a reference type
each of the the things you see here or
the the
properties
this here is known as the primary
Constructor or default Constructor
so with a record
doesn't have to have a body let's say we
have record person
I can say string first name String last
name
what this here is now doing it's
producing a class with two backing
fields that are in it only so it's
immutable it exposes them using a public
property so I can access first and last
name it also gives me value-based
equality so if I compare two instances
with each other it will compare the
values of first name and last name which
is tremendously useful
it also gives me a way to get a string
representation of this entire instance
not Json but it looks similar great for
logging for example
just be careful so you don't log any
sensitive data
so with that being said I've created
this test result that has two primary
parameters or two two properties that
are required for this Constructor I've
also introduced a body because it's
normal reference type it's a normal
class behind the hoods so I can add
methods Fields properties and whatever I
want
I've introduced a separate
method here called deconstruct now this
here is a magic method as long as you
have a publicly exposed method called
deconstruct spelled exactly like this
with two or more out parameters
what you will be able to do
is let me show you
let me show you I can take an instance
of a test result so I've already
prepared that I have a couple of test
results or test results is equal to
results this is an array of
of test results if I do this and I can't
spell
now if I want to get
these different so the test day sends an
archived if I want to get that into
separate variables I can deconstruct
this object
so I can do a b c is equal to test
result
test result
now this doesn't make any sense at all
so this we should probably avoid
such shorthand variable names
the problem here is Visual Studio isn't
really telling me what it's being
deconstructed into except that I can
hover this here and I can see that well
the first thing is a daytime offset so
that's probably the test date
I think the second one is an integer so
that would probably be the number of
tests
and the last one is is archived it
doesn't have to be the same name that I
use for my deconstruct method but
basically if I have this here
I can take my object or my instance and
I can deconstruct that into separate
variables which is handy when it comes
to pattern matching
so we can leave that for now but
that illustrates exactly what what is
generated by a record type
now
there are multiple different ways that I
can use pattern matching I can use it
with if statements I can use them with
my switch expression so for example
let's say that instead of test result
being my actual instance here so I have
created this method called get tests
just returns a couple of failed ones and
then finally a past test
doesn't really matter exactly what this
is doing we can move that down there
now let's say that I want this variable
here to contain a string representation
of the result I can instead say well
based on what the first thing is that I
get out of this I can produce patterns
to determine if it's a failed test
I can capture this this here is called a
declaration pattern to to declare that
as a variable
so failed
there we go
and I can find past ones
right so I can use the type pattern and
then I can use a Discord the discard
means everything else
it means null it means whatever
it's the same as VAR
so if I do the Vore pattern that will
also match on nulls
that's something that you should keep in
mind
so if I undo that I'm going to use the
Discord
and I'm going to say if it's failed past
and in con
oh wow look at that I think it's the
first time actually succeeded spelling
this word
perfect so it's inconclusive now I can
fill this with more patterns so I
mentioned that well this here is now
using the type pattern but maybe I want
to be a little bit more granular maybe I
want to also check a property
so we could say that well if it's failed
or rather if it's if it's failed
let's just remove this here to make it a
little bit easier or
I don't care about the type
so this here will first of all it will
ensure that it sets to an instance and
then I can access a property to say well
if the number of attempts are more than
10 I'm going to consider that you failed
this test
right
so this here not having set passed
failed or whatever here this will match
on anything where that property is set
to to 10.
I could also say that well it has to be
less than 20 because if you've done this
more than more than 20 actually should
be less than right less than 10.
more than 10 and less than 20.
you get the idea if you've done this
more than 20 times like I don't care
then I don't want to see or you're doing
this test again
so between 10 and 20. so this is a very
easy way for me to construct a way for
me to express what I'm looking for like
I can do this with an if statement but
it gets a little bit easier on the eyes
just to look at it like this here
now I could also
parenthesize this here
and this is something that you should
probably avoid because what happens if I
negate this entire pattern
similar to any language feature of C
sharp you should avoid abusing the
language features and avoid writing code
that doesn't make any sense
I've seen people abuse pattern matching
to instead of saying false for a Boolean
they do not true
which works but it's just more
characters to to say the same thing
so now this here is doing two things we
have the type pattern it's recursively
looking up the next thing because it's
an or pattern we're looking at the the
property
and we're using a relational and pattern
so pattern matching in this case here is
really powerful
now surely enough that's on one object
and I can do the same thing I can take
this out
it doesn't have to be with a switch
expression I can say well if if results
is results Dot
first
is
there we go
I can do that as well I can use it with
the if statement I can use it with a
switch expression I can use this
wherever I want
if you want a fancy way of performing a
null check
you can say well if
if
I can't even spell if results first
is set to an instance
that's the same as saying it's not null
quite handy
all right and now with C sharp 11 what
we got is something called a list
pattern
so we got the normal type patterns
checking property values the Tuple
patterns and so forth you can use all of
that and explore that on your own now
but another thing in C sharp 11 is a way
for me to look at this array so I've
I've produced an array here instead of
an i enumerable because it has to be an
array in order for me to slice off some
information because I'm going to use
more than one thing
so I could for instance say that well if
let's do it uh let's do if results
or result is equal to results switch
and now I'm going to produce patterns
for this
if I can spell
there we go
now I'm going to produce patterns for
this array instead
and what I can do now is to say well if
the first value
has failed and I don't care about the
rest then I'm going to enter this this
get this result
right
if it's whatever like I don't care I can
use a discard again
I can also say well if the first one is
failed
I don't care about the last one but I'd
like to get the middle elements
so now it skips the first and the last
element
and I'm getting everything else in the
middle so why is this a big thing or a
big deal imagine instead of having this
made up test results already it could
have been the payload coming in from
data I know how how long the header is
there's a couple of bytes that I'm
looking for this here could be the value
of those first couple of bytes and then
it could be slicing off the information
in the middle and if this was a span
that would be a very memory efficient
way to do that
so this was introduced in C sharp 11.
so patterns in in C sharp is powerful
and I promise that we'll see even more
patterns being added in the next
versions of c-sharp as well
so with C sharp 9 out of the way we can
take a look at some more things from C
sharp 10. now given that C sharp 9
introduced record that produces
reference types and classes obviously it
would be a good idea to also allow us to
do record structs value types
they work similar to to the reference
types but by default the record strikes
aren't immutable so you have to mark
them as read only if you're creating a
record struct a little gotcha
there's some other improvements there's
something called a global using
directive
so if you add the global keyword in
front of your using then it will become
available for all your classes in your
solution or in your project
we saw the file scope namespace
declaration and this is a way well and
was introduced because of minimal apis
minimal apis is a way for you to produce
on asp.net core application in a
program.cs file with just a couple of
lines of code like less than 10 lines of
code
many of these features are added to
cater for that to make it easier for
many other developers to to jump in and
learn c-sharp and use it for
microservices or or Nano services or
whatever you want to call the the new
cool thing
there's an extended property pattern so
if I if I were to go back to my solution
here and this here's a property pattern
if I were to access another thing here
let's just say
get type for example
or if that was let's just say that it
had a length
if this had the property length it would
automatically perform a null check when
I do a DOT here which is quite handy so
you don't have to do multiple null
checks
they've improved some some improvements
to Lambda Expressions you can do
constant interpolated strings which is a
tiny feature but still important
so imagine you have two constant strings
and you want to interpolate that for
example in this case the version number
you couldn't do this prior to C sharp
10.
which was a little bit odd but a more
important feature is inferring the
delegate type so this is the Improvement
to well this isn't the Improvement
because this is from C sharp nine but in
C sharp nine you were required to
specify explicitly which delegate type
that you were using
so I could say funk string of integer
here but instead why couldn't just the
compiler figure this out it knows that
I'm expecting a string to be passed into
this Anonymous method and it knows that
I'm returning an integer so why couldn't
it just infer that
and surely enough that's what C sharp 10
is doing
so here is an example of a minimal API
now the minimal apis is a way for you to
create this asp.net core application in
a very tiny program.cs file
but they've added one feature at a time
to the different versions of c-sharp
into.net and they constantly improve
upon this so with C sharp 9 we got the
top level statements which made this
possible but now with C sharp 10 they
added attributes in Lambda so that we
can in this case here I can say that the
parameter passed into this get method is
coming from a header for example
which is quite handy so while C sharp 10
didn't introduce groundbreaking features
like nullable reference types or record
classes it's still quite a lot of tiny
changes to cater for the future
C sharp 11 on the other hand introduced
what I showed you earlier the list
patterns and I have another example of
this as well
what I didn't tell you is that I sliced
off a portion using the slice pattern so
the patterns introducing C sharp 11
allows you to grab that middle portion
of the array and slice it off in a very
memory efficient manner
you can name of parameter which isn't
such a big deal
a big deal though is that they're now
caching the Delegate for static method
groups which is if you've ever run into
this this could have caused a
performance hit or a performance penalty
another finally caching that
the required property we're introduced
in c-sharp 11 to allow you to now use
nullable reference types A little bit
better
so I can say that this property is now
required the compiler in the visual
studio will tell you that it's required
so that you're when you're creating this
instance either with a Constructor or
you know with a with expression for
example
it will tell you that you should do that
there's something called a raw string
literal
static members and interfaces utf-8
string literals everything that's coming
over the web is basically utf-8 c-sharp
by default is utf-16 so whenever you get
a string into your application and you
tell your
aceput.net.net core endpoint to expect a
string it has to convert that into UTF
16 from utf-8 might sound silly but in
the grand scheme of things that is a
little bit time consuming it requires a
couple of CPU Cycles to do so which is
not necessarily what you want so instead
we can have a utf-8 string literal I can
say that I expect this string or I have
this constant string in my case here I
append the u8 after this ring and now
this here is a span of bytes
which again is really handy if you're
working with interop with Hardware where
everything comes in as bytes and you're
looking for a particular payload for
example
I use this extensively so I don't have
to convert back and forth to Strings
makes the code a little bit more clean
there's generic math support generic
attribute so I can now say that my class
has a generic attribute for example I've
wanted this feature since I started with
asp.net MVC probably 10 years ago
it took a long time to implement maybe
it wasn't important earlier but now it
is
there was something called parameter
null checking I don't know if anyone's
ever seen this but they removed this
from the language so let's go into let's
say this method here
who is here doesn't matter what it's
doing
and that's a parameter imagine so they
removed this feature imagine if I just
did double bangs
they had this in a preview version of
the compiler they were very sure that
they were going to ship this
many of the internal teams at Microsoft
refactored all their Solutions on GitHub
to use this
what it did was that it automatically
null checked on the parameter so
basically what this introduced was an
argument null exception throw if null
people
so this way you can do double bangs
instead of having to write that entire
code snippet
many people didn't like this for the
reason that it adds it adds a little bit
too much code that's potentially
crashing right so this isn't really the
best adding double bangs had a much
bigger side effect than you might have
hoped for
so again like if we go into GitHub and
participate in the discussions we can
influence what they're doing and and why
they would want to focus on a feature or
why they might not that might not be a
good idea so many people reach out and
now they remove that so if you've
been out of the game and you haven't
followed what's happened for the past
few years they had to remove that
because
no one wanted it
so the list patterns here's another
example of that
from c-sharp 11. so I have a list of
names here
I can now say that well if the first one
is Philip I'm going to grab all the
middle names and then if the last one
matches what I'm looking for I can say
that at the second pattern here I can
say I don't care about the first one as
long as the second one is a particular
value and then it also followed by more
of them so I can do a lot of interesting
things with list patterns with with all
the other types of patterns as well and
this here uses works with the array as
well which is why I can also slice off a
portion of of the middle part
and I think in C sharp 13 14 15 and how
much longer we're going to go we're
going to see more patterns added to the
language as well which is good
now raw spring literals allows us to
produce a string here I have a a three
double quotes and that allows me to then
in this case write XML which also has a
capability of doing string interpolation
so I can inject my connection string
into this into this XML here
looks very much like XML literals or
whatever you want to call them from from
VB
but you can write Json and visual studio
has syntax highlighting for the code
that you write in your rostering literal
quite handy
so the utf-8 string electorals here's an
example of how to take my name and
convert that into a read-only spot span
of bytes
I can then use this payload
to say that I want to find the index of
the utf-8 space that's a very quick
operation to look for it and then I can
say I want to at the at line seven here
I can say I want to grab my first name
so I'm using a a range syntax to say
that give me all the characters up until
the space and then on the next line on
line nine I'm saying jump over the space
and give me the rest
and what's interesting with this code
snippet is that it's pretty much
allocation free there's a couple of
variables declared on the stack and
obviously my name is allocated somewhere
but the slicing operation the looking
for the index none of that has to copy
any data over to another memory position
so they've done this extensively in
in.net and then asp.net core and the
performance is just shooting through the
roof because they don't have to copy any
memory over
there are some God chests with this but
you know it's it's a really great way to
work with uh with data
so abstract members and interfaces was
also introduced in c-sharp 11. in this
case here I have an interface that
dictates that you should have an
instance defined on your on your classes
but in older versions of c-sharp this
didn't really give us a warning or
didn't tell me anything much like the
default interface implementations it
doesn't tell me that I have to add
something
but if I mark it as abstract
with c-sharp 11 this is now going to
tell me that the class person here
doesn't Implement that particular
interface which is a good addition
so now with C sharp 8 through 11 out of
the way we've looked at some of the
really important language features
a heavy workload that's been put into
doing pattern matching well to get
nullable reference types built really
well and adding support in the language
to to avoid nulls and hopefully we can
all agree that it's a good investment in
the language and what I think is great
about all of these language features
added to c-sharp is that most of them
feel like they belong in C sharp and
that's probably one of the challenges
working on the compiler that they have
to make sure that it feels like a
c-sharp language feature
surely they can take inspiration from
kotlin Swift Java and many other
programming languages but it still has
to for a c-sharp developer feel familiar
and I believe most of these does so
what's next we can jump onto to GitHub
and look through all of the different
features that are coming
but out of experience I know that many
of the language features that are talked
about and worked upon they might be
coming in the next version of like after
so we have C sharp 12 coming in in
November
but I would be surprised if the change
that they've released now stays the same
like they have to ensure that the
tooling is there everything has to work
perfectly well and no bugs and and no
Community backlash for some of these
features
but with c-sharp 12 we're going to see
some interesting additions
so how about we take inspiration from
records and introduce something called
primary Constructors on classes
now if someone's really sharp on the
eyes here you'll notice that
I haven't written these in upper case
so I have my class user and there's a
primary Constructor that expects a name
and a registration date
but with a record I made them uppercase
is this a spelling mistake on my hand or
is it just that they're different the
fact is that they are actually different
with a primary Constructor on a class
all that's generated here are backing
fields so if I fire up IL spy we can see
that this here introduced The
Constructor
and it also introduced the backing
fields
but with a record it introduced publicly
exposed properties that were set to init
only but with this we they didn't want
to make such a big change to your class
or what's generated so you have to add
that yourself I mean as you'll see here
I can I can access these fields inside
my override of two strings so I could
just as well have exposed a publicly
exposed property and set these to the
default value
they're also making lambdas a little bit
better by introducing something called
optional parameters or default Lambda
parameters
it's a small addition but you know since
we're doing a lot of minimal apis and
that's the next big thing this is a good
addition to it so in this case here I
can say that my Lambda has a default
parameter and if I call it with or
without a particular value that just
works
so now there's
two more features in C sharp 12 that I
think are are going to make make the cut
there's there's this thing called Alias
any type
so I could say
somewhere in my code file I could say
using point is equal to this Tuple or
Tuple depending on how you like to
pronounce that so if it's the first time
you see a tuple
this here creates a value toppled behind
the scenes with which has two Fields a
field X and field y
but instead of having to create a
wrapper structure wrapper class I can
simply say whenever I refer to a point
that's going to then use my my topple
which is great
and if I append the global keyword in
front of that it's going to be globally
available for my entire project
that's why I didn't have to do anything
inside my my program.cs file to use Link
for example because they are inferring
where the namespaces are coming from and
they're doing a lot of that compiler
magic that we love behind the scenes
another feature that are is possibly
coming to C sharp 12
it's something called interceptors which
is also an inspiration from other
programming languages like Objective C
for example has had this for a very long
time
imagine that I have this little code
snippet here super simple class called a
logger which has a publicly exposed
method called log which takes a message
it then calls an internal method which
is simply throwing an exception
now I'd like to intercept this method
call I'd like to intercept what happens
when you call log internal so what I can
do is that I can create something called
an interceptor
simply apply an attribute called
intercept location in this case and in
this state of this language feature I
have to know the line inside this file
so line number five I have to also know
the column or or how many characters in
that method signature starts but I can
write code that figures this out for me
and then what I'm doing is that I'm
intercepting this using my
console.writeline code snippet that I
have here so it takes the class of
logger it takes the same parameter
called a message as an input and then I
can use this
so the interesting thing with this
imagine that I pulled down a nuget
package
and it just magically intercepts some of
my method calls without me having to
know about it
sounds dangerous but it's probably not
you can very easily say which kind of of
interceptors you allow in your
application so there's no really not
really any security concerns
but it's interesting because this here
now allows me to intercept this call and
and do other things so with Source
generators and interceptors I can use
this to replace functionality or add
functionality
quite easily
and I do have one more feature I want to
show you I'll have to jump over to
visual studio and hopefully it's still
there
there's this thing called a collection
expression I'm almost out of time so
I'll show you this quite quickly so here
I've constructed an integer array of
with data and an innumerable of integer
I'd like to concatenate these two
together
previously you had to write a little bit
of a particular code to do this create a
temporary list add all the elements or
use Link to produce this now I can use a
collection expression to say hey I want
to grab everything from data and
everything for more data and just create
me a new collection
and this now produces
if I run this here that should produce
uh one through ten so as you'll see here
it prints one to ten because I took all
the data one through six and seven to
ten and put them together in one array
so just a little bit of a shorthand way
of writing something that's that's quite
nice
so with these features being added to C
sharp 12 there's there's quite a lot
happening happening to C sharp it can be
quite tricky to keep up I've got a lot
of courses on pluralsight that I'll have
to go back and update with some of these
really new interesting language features
but if you like my stuff you can always
check out my course on plural side and
it's interesting because I I always end
with the slides and I tell people to hey
send me an email if you have any
questions and and for the past 10 years
like I've never got any emails
do you know why because I forgot to put
my email on the slide
not the best thing so now my email is
here take a photo of that if you want to
I'm happy to discuss everything around
c-sharp and what's happening with dotnet
performance there's a lot happening and
I just love talking about these
different things I hope you've enjoyed
this and the conference remember to vote
on your way out and thank you so much
for for spending this hour with me
[Applause]